-It's all so crazy right now.
I really think people
are just losing it.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I was walking to work today.
I saw this angry man who was
yelling about all this stuff.
And he wouldn't stop.
He wouldn't stop yelling.
And I thought if he's got
something to say,
let's just bring him
on the show tonight.
So come on out.
Here's the angry guy
I saw on the street.
Here he is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Yeah, folks.
Thank you, thank you.
Folks.
There is this annoying trend
in advertising now,
especially on cable, where they
want you to get to know
the non-celebrity spokesman
for whatever the product is.
There's one running on CNN
right now.
It says, "Bob is 68 years old.
Bob has hemorrhoids.
Learn more about Bob's story
on hemorrhoids.com."
I don't want to know
Bob's story, okay?
[ Laughter ]
How empty is my life that I have
time to go to this website?
Hey, if I want to see
hemorrhoids,
I can stand in the bathroom
with a hand mirror, okay?
I don't need to go to
some stupid website.
And what do I do
when I get to the website?
E-mail him pictures of
my hemorrhoids now?
What, we in some kind of
a hemorrhoid club?
I don't care.
Oh, and listen to this.
Medical marijuana experts
now say you can cure hemorrhoids
using marijuana.
Let me tell you something.
Okay, no.
If you think you can cure
hemorrhoids with the marijuana,
somebody's just blowing smoke
up your ass, okay?
That's all I have to say.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, oh, no, no, no, no.
So then, last week I go into
the Apple store to get
another $29 six-inch white
charge cord for my iPhone.
[ Laughter ]
And the guy says to me,
"What iPhone do you have?"
I said, "I got 7S."
"7S?
Oh, man, you got to upgrade.
How about our 10th anniversary
iPhone?"
I said, "How much is that?"
He goes, "A thousand dollars."
It's a thousand dollars
for the 10th anniversary iPhone.
I didn't spend $1,000 on my
10th wedding anniversary, okay?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, that was pretty much
Sizzler and a Hallmark card.
[ Laughter ]
Then he says, "Oh, you need it,
because it has
the new improved camera."
How much more camera do you need
on your iPhone?
What are you using this for?
Colonoscopies?
What level of detail --
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, look how much bigger
Uncle Ken's nostril hairs are
with this new camera."
And it's huge.
It's literally a tablet.
Have you seen how big it is?
See people at the airport
walking around with it.
You look like Moses carrying
the 10 Commandments
with your stupid iPhone.
Anyway, I just came in from L.A.
This is another annoying --
Here's something you do
in Los Angeles, okay?
My wife and I
go to the supermarket.
We buy $128 worth of groceries.
And the clerk says,
"You want a bag for that?"
"No, we're going to eat it here.
Okay, that's fine."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna put the ice cream
in my pants.
I'll put the hamburger
in my shirt."
Really, I only spent a $128
to ask for a bag.
I feel like I'm taking too much,
really.
I'm taking advantage.
Oh, and then I do that
credit-card swipe thing,
you know, with the plastic pen
on a little chain.
Why the chain?
Who is stealing that? Okay?
[ Laughter ]
First of all,
it's not even a pen.
It's a plastic stick, okay?
So I go to sign,
and I'm trying to sign.
I go, "Miss, excuse me, miss.
This isn't working."
She goes,
"Oh, don't worry about it."
Don't worry about it?
Isn't that the essence of
credit-card fraud --
"don't worry about it"?
[ Laughter ]
And then she just, "Oh, you can
sign with your finger."
You ever sign with your finger?
And then you look at
your signature.
Looks like it was written by
a nymphomaniac sitting on
a washing machine.
Woo-hoo-woo!
[ Laughter ]
And let me ask something.
And what is this -- what is
this annoying trend now?
We have stores
inside of other stores.
The supermarket we went to
had a Coffee Bean
inside the supermarket.
And inside the Coffee Bean
was a Starbucks.
Okay, it didn't make any sense.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, listen to this.
Amazon announced they're going
to be opening stores nationwide
with no sales clerks
of any kind.
First of all,
that's not new, okay?
Sears had that 20 years ago,
okay?
[ Laughter ]
You ever try to buy something
at Sears?
"Hello. I'm trying to pay for
this Kenmore suit.
Hello? Hello?
Anybody here? Hello?"
What happened?
What happened to Sears?
Remember when Sears was Amazon?
Remember those days,
you got that catalog,
you found what you wanted
and boom --
eight weeks later
it was right there.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I am out of here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Screw you, Fallon!
-Oh, my God. Get out.
Angry man -- oh, my God.
-Oh, my God.
-Kicking the door, my God.
-Wow!
-Jay Leno, everybody,
right there.